bro
i'll sit here and say shut up i'll say
make me because i'll be whamming it i'll
say make me
you put your hand across my chest bam
you stop me forgetting the camera oh
grab your wrist and you'll feel it and
i'll say make me
[Music]
show you where i'm making straight in
school
i can show you why i'm making strings at
school
what a waste line that was
i can show you why i'm making streaks of
schools
that literally makes no sense bro it
doesn't correlate together it doesn't in
anything i don't know what he was on
about he was just trying to make things
right yeah
bless his cotton socks back then
i can show you why i'm making straight
a's in school
ruby maybe he's trying to say i can pay
attention to you i'm a i'm a good
listener you're giving him too many
props bro someone told him to say that
um
[Music]
while going guys
i'm gonna be honest
your boy was a bit moody earlier today
i was freaking
effing moody mate you've had a couple
shots i've had five i'd say a couple
i've had five shots
five sip sips to be precise
with some don julio
and i feel much better yeah i can
understand
why stay at home moms
drink it like two
because they've got nothing else they've
got [ __ ] all to do and they're pissed
off yeah
especially when they don't have hobbies
and they're just like they just sit at
home vex why are you merely rocking bro
why wouldn't i minnie rock
that's the question i'm gonna pose to
you why wouldn't i really rock right now
fair enough exactly shut your mouth
oh i'm sorry anyway guys happy monday
happy monday
uh
the
flipping the what the ignorance has done
now in it it's done you had your chance
the other seven days it's done yeah yeah
if you didn't copy it you copped out you
had to charge and you bottled it you
absolutely bought it unless you didn't
bottle it and you've got a couple gums
um on that front guys
we just want to say
we couldn't be more grateful for what
you guys did with that merch
honest it was just like a little
sometime right sweetheart's idea and was
like oh what if we just make it limited
edition uh because it's ick related
obviously you don't want to typecast
yourself you don't even notice like
these [ __ ] eight guys and we're like
all right cool man let's just do the ick
merch everyone keeps asking for it we
did it we launched it we gave it seven
days and i swear to god we launched at
midnight we had sales sales going
through the roof at 1201 1201 it was
yeah and that's mad to me doesn't matter
so thank you yeah mad to us so thank you
guys um very very much i hope you
enjoyed it i hope you got as much as you
can handle
um and if it's a resale thing let your
boys wet their beak yeah
come on if there's a resale thing let me
wet my beak yeah really give me a little
something we need to hold some of that
profit a little commish we need to hold
some of that profit yeah yeah because if
you're if you're a big reseller because
obviously we get approached by the huge
resellers the big boys hypebeast [ __ ]
you know crep sauce all these thoughts
all these things bro they're always
hitting up saying oh let's have some
stock so we can result in we said nah
nah nah it's not fair to the consumer
but since you men are going to be
reselling the thing anyway
your boy's got as much stock as you need
yeah just throw it out there
let me wet my beak your boy's got as
much stuff as you possibly need yeah um
anyway moving on
obviously guys you already know the
drill by now you need to pause this
episode right now f in now
you need to pause the episode right f in
now head on over to
patreon.com forward slash shits and gigs
and you can get
two years worth of episodes on there a
whole two years
we're done we said the other day that we
were like a year in yeah that was mine
that was three hours
purely
and i just it's also my fault because i
just went just let it happen we were out
that night and i for some reason it
bumped into my head and i thought a
year's too short bro two years that's
how two years we are yeah yeah two years
so you've got two years worth of content
on uh patreon two years bro two
years ago again for the people about two
years worth of uh content on patreon.com
full size shits and gigs hop on over
there get
all the content and every thursday
you'll get a new episode on there it's
gonna cost you three pound a month that
equates to tempo a day run the p please
pretty please
um
also guys if you are watching this on
the old youtube make sure to
like the video if you like the video use
those two fingers of death on the
notification bell
and make sure you know whenever we're
releasing stuff because now we just feel
like releasing yeah we just drop stuff
now now we just drop stuff dude you've
got your episodes every monday you can
count on that you've got your patreon
patreon patreon episode i [ __ ] get my
words out bro monday's episode that's
guaranteed thursday you've got a patreon
episode that's guaranteed but in between
we just do what we want we can post and
we might post when and we're never aware
of ourselves yeah so make sure the
notification bell is on so you know
whenever we're posting in short form um
on top of that guys making sure your
chirps and editing in the comments if
you're listening on spotify apple
podcast google podcast whatever you
listen wherever you listen to your
podcast please give us a rating give us
a nice review uh it means a lot to us it
goes a long way in terms of spreading
the word white robes and yeezys is the
uniform to build this cult okay you know
the dream build the cult chirps a ting
in the comments we need breeding grounds
we need to use to indoctrinate into the
cult
so we can go for generations yeah yeah
yeah yeah we're not going to be here
forever we can't be as much as we'd like
to be we can't be you know so we have to
keep this thing rolling we have to keep
the ball rolling so as jimmy said
sign up yeezys white robes chirp sitting
let's get these utes involved
boom they're going to continue the race
for us
um you know what yeah well
i promised myself i was never going to
do it but i'm actually going to do it
what i'm actually going to do it what
guys if you head on over to patreon.com
forward start shits and gigs i'm
actually you know what [ __ ] i'm going to
do it head on over to patreon right now
anyone who signs up this month
anyone who signs up in the month of
march
dm me
prove to me that you signed up yeah yeah
show me the little call yeah
congratulations message screenshot that
yeah and i'll tell you what i've got my
pokemon top
oh
okay yeah bagaman have been asking me
man
same place i've got this little goku
yeah say less um say less now that what
the egg much is out the way
do you hear me once you sign up to
patreon and i'll tell you and that that
counts for everyone who's already on
patreon i don't want to dismiss you yeah
yeah um but yeah if you want to know
where i've got my my pokemon tops plural
tops
um sign up to patreon dme prove to me
that you're on the patreon and you're
really part of the gang and you really
want to be part of these breeding
grounds yeah man and i will tell you
where i've got my uh my tops on
yeah you got that off of your happy i
got that yeah oh fam
you know what it'd be i think i
mentioned this earlier off camera
um so i'm gonna give props to
um
one of our patrons
alexis
yes okay what about so alexis tunes into
our tier two patreon zoom call every
month for the last goodness how many
months
um recently she was looking bad i'm not
gonna lie
in this
[Laughter]
yeah yeah
anyway
that's joe's she was like a pissed
yesterday
anyway
she was mentioned that she's on this
fitness journey with us yes yes she did
she did she did and i'm not gonna lie
i've been doing what i need to do yeah
but not doing what i should be doing oh
i completely agree with my with you by
myself january i was on it yeah february
was a bit um fam
now
i said it earlier your boy's on it gang
your boys on it gang and the thing is as
well i've been training recently i've
got a boy called josh who i train with
who's a big fan of the pod and he always
tells me to say hi to you and i never
remember to say it so
he always says hi forehead
so
anyway i train with josh sometimes and
he's a strong brother and he makes me
realize that i ain't been lifted heavy
enough okay i ain't been training hard
enough bro
i've just been out here just doing what
relatively relatively you outcomes yeah
yeah so i remember a few months ago when
i was on it after lockdown actually not
a few like a year ago okay after
lockdown i was bang when the gyms opened
i was in there bro for a good few months
i was in there in there in there
and i was uh
dumbbell press dumbbell chest press i
had the 52s out
and i was
i got a good last year this was last
year okay i'll get good set and i
thought you know what i'm [ __ ]
strong bro yeah yeah i'm actually strong
yeah yeah yeah yeah
you know yeah
yeah
yeah you know what yeah i'm actually
[ __ ] strong yeah i'm not going to sit
here and have this yeah
because if i lift it like this all the
time yeah i will be much bigger and much
stronger
in better shape
obviously i did what
i always do which is i did one set on
52s one day
finished the other two sets on like 50s
or whatever and i was like [ __ ] yeah i'm
strong the next week drop all the way
back down to like 37
all the way down to like 30 seconds and
stuck there for like six months yeah so
train my boy josh the other day for the
first time in a while
[Music]
and he immediately grabbed like the 50s
i was like let's go first set no
warm-ups we'd like two warm-up sets and
then you grabbed the 50s what's going to
say okay 50s on an incline oh yeah
and i felt like my shoulder was going to
pop out i [ __ ] imagine bro but anyway
it made me realize i got through it and
i thought why am i not doing this all
the time when you have when you're with
someone it's different i know sometimes
it's different when you listen but fam i
realized that i need to be doing this
all the [ __ ] time
like i'm tired of just like sticking in
my comfort zone i'm not getting any
stronger i'm not getting any bigger i'm
not really pushing myself yeah so this
last week i've been pushing it i had two
reasons to motivate me one i looked to
the mirror and i looked like a thumb
i looked in the mirror and i looked like
a thumb i looked at those brothers from
uh spy kids do you remember
do you remember the first spy kids and
he has those minions that are thumbs
walk around i think i look like homeboy
i think so um so
one reason to motivate me is i look like
a thumb and i'm tired of it yeah
i've also got hundreds of pounds worth
of supplements in my yard and i haven't
been taking them i've been the one that
used to the one i subscribed to i've
been taking it because they ship it to
you y'all regardless okay they dropped
your money and they shipped it
so when you get two when you've got two
cases of it yeah it's you you're hearing
alarm bells
where's my money yeah where's my muscles
wasting money yeah yeah yeah so i've
been taking those vitamins but i've got
like protein and creatine in my yard and
amino acids in my eye that i just ain't
been taken
so i've been on a big shopper for the
weekend i've got mad porridge
blueberries i've got my protein i've got
my creatine i'm ready i've got steaks
galore i've got chicken galore i've got
rice galore your boy's ready to turn up
nice
come june july peak summer you think i
won't do this topless yeah
look me in my eye like a man you think i
won't do this that's topless you said
that last year i know what i said said
that i also said i was gonna jump out
but here we are
i was thinking about that earlier i was
thinking like yesterday it's been your
it's been your birthday it's been your
third my birthday's coming up next month
next month you think i won't do
it we've got more subscribers now yeah
more accountability yeah yeah yeah
that's the way i say it more success
more followers more accountability we'll
jump out of a plane and come summertime
i will do this podcast let's say less
i'm going to spot on it i'm scared to
spot on it because i know what that
really means that it's really real now
it's really real now cool say yes
because we've got a wedding to go to in
august in
port not portugal what's it called
madeira madeira it's portugal similar no
it's not possible
tell someone from madeira
in my head i feel like his talent is
calling that irish person english
okay makes sense that's why in my head
that's where i see it okay so we've got
a wedding in august in madeira and your
boy's got to be looking chef's kiss so
just before that i'll do it topless okay
i'm terrified now that i've put that in
the universe
[ __ ] it i need accountability in my life
because i'm lazy bro
sometimes same i'm gonna be one yeah and
lean
so what's going to happen is i'm going
to sit down
and i'm not even going to tell you
what's happening i'm going to drape my
top off
i'm going to baby-roll it in the toilet
before and i'm going to drape my top off
and i'm just going to sit here and wait
for your reaction
bro
i would be
i would either be
jealous or horny
no
yeah sorry go go go go go go go
jealous
or
vex that
i've probably not done gone as hard as i
wanted to go i want plan b i want the
second i want the latter i would like to
look at me and think [ __ ] i put my
jumper on yeah i want to say yeah
because i don't want to
obviously i want to talk about gym stuff
today but i don't want to bring it down
because it's on you
because it's on you now yeah yeah yeah i
want to get here in like july yeah early
august
rip my top off
i'm not i'm gonna wear a cheap top
rip it off
and just sit here and say nothing and i
want you to say [ __ ] i haven't been
doing it because i'll say and etude
[Laughter]
and if you say nah
the whole world's gonna know about it
[Laughter]
so i'm warning you now
between july and august early august
yeah i will be ripping off unprovoked
and i might wear long sleeves because
you might start seeing veins earlier i
think it's coming yeah so i want to be
if i see vascularity like mid-june i'm
running i'm running to the gym
running to the gym
that incline tread five minutes yeah
yeah what a sweat when we start doing
sip zips before the show and i decline
pineapple juice you know what's up okay
i don't want that fructose in my
bloodstream i don't need that
i don't want any more carbs than i need
so um yeah hilarious come late july
august yeah i'm gonna tear up preferably
with one hand
i'm gonna when i'm
and you've got two options stay where
you are or or follow suit can you stay
where you are
i'm gonna snigger
i'll just go no black
and then i'm going to carry on i'm going
to look you up and down
and then i'm going to look at the camera
i won't look at you again for the rest
of the thing i will launch the camera
you man are getting a two-minute episode
because i will launch the [ __ ] camera
put your [ __ ] top on
bro
i'll sit here and say shut up i'll say
make me because i'll be whamming it i'll
say make me
you put your hand across my chest bam
just stop me forget the camera oh grab
your wrist and you'll feel it and i'll
say make me
oh my goodness that's the letter anyway
guys he's in the universe now i'm gonna
jump out of a plane in april maybe may
give me chance
my birthday's in april but just give me
like a six week
window yeah yeah
six week cushion
and it may or may not jump out of a
window but hopefully i will a window a
plane
i know what you mean and come july i
said june scrap dude come july late july
late july early august yeah random
episode you're going to hear shh
and then that's going to be it for you
audio listeners you're going to want to
scurry over to the yeah it's got be
viral on social media anyway so you've
got no choice
you'll you'll see it you'll be minding
your business and you'll just see it
so it's fine uh
wakes my boy
let me ask you a question bro hit me up
gee let me ask you a flipping question
talk to me my dog have you ever ever met
anyone who finds nose and ear hair
attractive i'll wait
of course not of course not cool
rhetorical questions
everyone hates a rhetorical question i
just posed a rhetorical question for you
of course not no one likes nose hair no
one finds nose hair attractive that's
why we need the weed whacker nose and
ear hair
trimmer
which provides pro
proprietary skin safe technology
only found that your boys are very
landscaped only only for only that's a
tm thing that's a copyright thing
proprietary skin safe technology
i'll tell you what that does it helps
reduce knicks snags
and tugs
tally whackers
and smacks
in those delicate nose and ear holes bro
it's all a necessity bro you know what
it's like when you've got a little
straggler yeah yeah yeah and your eyes
water and you're sneezing fam you can
feel it trickle down bro you can feel it
all down your face you're blowing your
nose for the rest of the day with your
boys over at man's head you ain't gotta
worry about that you can just give it a
quick because
yeah yeah and you don't need to look
like professor frink anymore bro
take care of that on top of that we've
got the pro little i was going to say
the prop preserver the crop preserve
preserver anti-chafing ball deodorant
and moisturizer you ain't never you
ain't never lived like this i thought
you're going to say i've never been with
a buddy
i've never been with a body bro
that's what word on the street that's
what i hear
i hear that's what happens when when
these have invested in the crop
preserver yeah eight anti-chafing
ball deodorant and moisturizer
when they're getting that slop top
all their hair is i never been with a
body
so
it's starting to get warm outside and
it's crucial that your balls stop
sticking to your leg big man if you're
hungry like your boy's over here yeah
that's an issue
and you need that anti-chafe so guys
what you need to do is you need to get
get your hands on this crop preserver
get your hands on the weed whacker and
the only way to do that is head on over
to manscape.com
manscape.com you might be looking at the
prices and think if this was one-fifth
cheaper i would snag it right away
well there you go we got all that for
we've got you we got you what you need
to do is use the code sng sierra
november golf thank you sir
manscape.com the code is sng you got 20
off and free shipping okay 20 off and
free shipping worldwide head on over to
manscape.com sierra november golf the
code is smg get your tings today
let's go back to the episode gang
speaking of um
i saw batman the other day oh [ __ ] i'm
watching it this week hopefully
hopefully i've heard it's potentially
one of the best batman's
oh potentially the best batman if you
had really
potentially the best batman really
better than dark knight
yes
oh
robert had it like that
person had it like that
really kravitz had it like that
okay
okay
okay
because obviously it was meant to come
out last year and i've seen like i've
been there i've seen so many little
teasers prior to the main trailer i'm
thinking it doesn't look that umph
but clearly didn't give it they clearly
didn't put a lot in the trailer on
purpose same way we did with spider-man
you know and the spider was [ __ ]
heavy
but okay it's a move would you say it's
the best dc movie going period yeah
it's better than justice league is
better than justin lee was whack i've
never seen the four-hour one but which
i've heard is very good yeah a lot
better i should say oh i've seen it it's
not that great oh really oh i've seen it
it's not that great i heard it was a lot
better it's a lot better but it's not
cool it's not good it doesn't make it a
good movie
i've seen it bro oh that's a shame it
doesn't matter because the original was
a movie oh the original was [ __ ]
shocking well so rush but anyway let's
go back to the point the batman oh bro
it's a movie okay
i'm not gonna it's long that's three
hours that's what i'm here for but yeah
that's what i'm here for i love long
movies
it's one of one thing i will say it's
one of the few long movies the only
other time i felt like this was
lord of the rings return of the king
where there was like 20 that's a long
movie and there was like 20 minutes 15
20 minutes at the end where i thought
they could have cut that all out where
sam
some wise ganji went back and got
married to somehow from the shire
all these things bro and everyone's at
his wedding class and said his full name
samwise gandhi went back and got married
to some random chick yeah back at the
shire bro and i remember thinking
and that's at the end of the movie and
i'm thinking you've made us sit through
hours of this i don't want to see what
happens after yeah load the thing in the
volcano and let's wrap this up
because we've been here for hours yeah
um
there's bits in the batman where like
it's a three-hour movie and i love when
when directors aren't trying to
put out a three-hour movie i love it but
there's little bits in there where i
think we could have chopped that up
mm-hmm there's a bit where um without i
won't do any spoilers yeah of course not
but new movie i wouldn't do that to you
man
there's a bit where um
batman and catwoman are like riding my
motorcycles together
they're just riding fam
they're just right there's no there's
there's no logic to it no nothing
there's no end game to it okay they're
just driving okay and it's like two
three minutes long
and you're like
this is a waste of time okay this is a
waste of time okay and there's a couple
like chatty bits where you're like a
waste of time it doesn't get it doesn't
add anything to the plot it doesn't
answer any questions we're just chatting
cut it
cut it okay but apart from those bits
there's a few little bits
um
there's a cameo i won't spoil it there's
a cameo near the end from a certain
character that we really didn't need
okay um we really didn't need and it's
annoying
that they could have out of anyone from
the batman universe they could have
chosen a cameo from any other character
and it would have made it more relevant
but because they chose this character
you're like unnecessary
um
which will give it away a little bit but
anyway it's an arrest it's also an
irrelevant scene so even if i've spoiled
it for anyone it's irrelevant it doesn't
mean anything okay um
but
the movie as a whole
yeah
wow
it's a good yeah strong movie yeah it's
a strong movie i'm okay i'm i'm
surprised robert could put it down like
that he puts it down the only thing the
only few critiques i have
without again without spoiling anything
is
the
it's the only kind of bruce wayne really
that robert patterson could probably
pull off
because
in the other batman like bruce wayne is
a is a [ __ ] boy basically okay he's a
playboy he's suave and cool as [ __ ] in
this this bruce wayne robert patterson's
bruce wayne is basically like an emo kid
okay he's a a recluse okay like a proper
hermit he doesn't like seeing anyone
okay and he's proper like hair slicked
down and like very cause i was gonna say
sorry to cut you off i was going to say
do you think he played a better batman
than christian bell but obviously you've
just said that they're two completely
different types the bruce waynes are
completely different the bet the batman
have no choice but to be okay okay bruce
wayne okay
i'm with you i'm with you i'm with you
now i'm with you now yes yes yes yes
bruce wayne's are definitely very
different i'm with you the batman
are similar
but there's a lot more
theater to robert patterson's batman
than there is to
um
christian because as well as um what's
his face from justice league what's his
name
[ __ ] ben affleck
some i saw on tick tock or something or
somewhere so no no it wasn't i was
talking to one of our boys and he said
he saw a tweet from someone saying ben
affleck's the best batman he should be
crucified wow whoever said ben affleck
who doesn't even have his own batman
movie
is the best batman
wow he's
off their [ __ ] head i thought i
couldn't get my words out there i also
find it weird how they recycle
um batman if that makes sense mm-hmm
kind of like
so quick yeah but it's it's so quick
it's very quick it's so quick
considering it's like a superhero movie
types it's like imagine they've got like
17 wolverine movies and stories imagine
they kept on changing hugh jackman
and it's it's still been hugh jackman
but i think that's more down to hugh
jackman as an actor rather than
the batman because i think they would be
happy to keep would have been happy to
keep making christian bell movies yeah
christian bell said i'm not doing any
more batman movies he said that okay um
so once that actor says i'm not doing
this anymore they have no choice but to
not only change the actor but change the
director change everything like we have
we have to come up with a brand new
concept
rather than just an act we can't just
replace the action yeah um
and i feel yeah so
the movie's [ __ ] sick robin patterson
like i said there's a lot more theater
and artistry in the shot the
cinematography is unbelievably good you
directed it
good question let me check director matt
reeves matt reeves so matt reeves give
contact also directed
matt reeves movies let's have a look see
oh okay cool this is actually a good
example okay so uh matt reeves directed
planet of the apes okay all of them uh
yeah oh merged um
cloverfield good movie
um
or interesting movie i would say what
else
oh wow he hasn't actually done that many
let me in
i've seen
oh i have seen that never saying that
let me in yeah the new ish let me in
from 2010. so he's done a couple he's
done a couple good movies
but um
props on the batman some of them i
haven't even seen
but yeah
good batman movie bro okay good man
there's patience obviously through our
movie there's a lot of patience in there
but good like suspense yeah not patience
there's suspense and there's theater
what they do
in this batman rather than even though
there's a lot of action in it
they put the fear of god
in you
about
there's a saying that says like i can't
remember there's a there's a saying from
some philosopher or something that says
like um
oh what is it
i've been afraid of like
i've been afraid of like thousands of
things in my life 90 percent of which
never happened
okay
and that's what they bring to the
character in this batman whereas in
christian bales batman he was just a
wham brother that we wanted to see [ __ ]
people up yeah yeah yeah yeah this
batman is more of like he's a few years
into the game
and the
they bring such darkness to it that the
criminals are afraid to commit
crimes oh man it's it's very
it's a very unique play and it's a
strong play okay
like they play like i said you're in
terms of playing the pauses like we
spoke about a few weeks ago in this
movie they play the pauses okay it's
it's good okay they're more concerned
about the threat of batman than batman
himself himself oh mad yeah yeah okay
it's good it's a mind [ __ ]
the movie's strong going because the
action in it is also very [ __ ] good
the actions is they're also very [ __ ]
strong okay um so
strong recommendation for the batman
definitely going to watch that hopefully
this week
this week strong recommendations good
movies something i've wanted for a while
um and then even like the villain the
villains in it are very good yeah um i
only know one main villain because
obviously from the adverts but yeah uh
the penguin yeah
no
the riddler oh sorry the riddler yeah
but yeah the penguins in it as well okay
you would have seen it he's in the
trailer though yeah yeah what about uh
that like car chase scene i didn't
remember the riddles i've seen i've seen
the bear question marks the riddler yeah
yeah terrifying
the riddlers played by um
do you remember the from you'd like this
as well because it's a perfect fit
remember prisoners
the movie we talked about yes yes yes
yes yes
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
the blackberry the black guy
no it's um and exactly it's from
hustle and flub and [ __ ] yeah yeah
crash
some other [ __ ] yeah i know how exactly
you're talking about
prisoners yeah the disabled brother that
they capture in prisoners he's a riddler
strong
chilling
if you might have not seen the prisoners
wow yeah strong play you know why i said
chilling he he he was yeah yeah
he was tapped tap so he's [ __ ] tapped
in batman okay so he he lent into it
even the more he doubled down oh say
less he's a strong riddler i'll say less
so um riddler's strong and the penguin
is very strong as well say less and the
penguin that i didn't even know until
afterwards you wouldn't know until
you've seen the movie even after i
didn't even know
colin farrell plays the penguin i swear
to god you will go in there knowing
that's current fell and not see cameron
pharaoh okay superb makeup job okay i
don't know how much weight he had to
gain to play this role okay strong job
okay movie okay batman's a movie i'm
looking forward to potentially the best
batman movie going okay
i'm looking forward to it good i'm very
much looking forward to it [ __ ] good
good movie but
um but yeah i'm vex i need to piss again
let's go for it and then we'll do
whatever you want to do
right so you've got trash news yeah but
random
quick left hand before the trash news
have you seen this is probably like semi
trash news before i go to the trash news
have you seen
this rick ross and this camel thing
rick ross camel have you seen it no
also before you show me yeah rick ross
has lost his mind recently explained
he posted a video a couple weeks ago of
him just chopping down a tree in his
[ __ ] garden i've not seen that fam he
did a video where he was like um
a few weeks ago where he was like i
tried to get a quote
on um get rid of some of these trees in
my back garden these [ __ ] try
to charge me a thousand dollars a tree
that's 10 grand for all the trees so i
told my boy run down to home depot told
this boy to run down to home depot
tomorrow run down to home depot give me
the biggest [ __ ] chainsaw
they've got and it's just him a video of
him chopping down trees and he's like
who do you think cares about this rick
rick
rose like
who do you think gives a [ __ ] that's
hilarious you're 68 years old
and you're chopping down trees in your
own yard because you don't want to pay
10 grand for someone else to do it this
is embarrassing but anyway sorry now
it's the camel team god yeah and he also
bought a cow like couple weeks ago
and you just let it run free and he's
lost his mind i'm telling you he's lost
his mind
it's just it's the facial expression
brother
so you he's in dubai
and he gets on it right he turn it down
easy to buy and gets on the camera
he's lost a lot of weight as well
what's making that noise the camel the
camel
the camel's had enough
stairs at the camera he's stare it's the
funniest meme i saw that
and i was like oh the way staring at the
camera is too funny but anyway let me go
to the trash news
so this is a play-by-play
um of a
whatsapp or imessage conversation right
so i read it out as opposed to showing
it to you
just for context and it's about a girl
that used to date teon wayne
here wayne's a rapper just for context
for guys i don't know uk uk rapper it's
from about a girl that used to date teon
wayne back in the day her name was lani
and lani
laney's sister actually went to our uni
back a day as well she bought for night
lonnie older sister the sister she was
cute
she was cute she was cute she was cute
were we there yeah we ah
i think she was younger than us so i
think maybe
yeah she was she would have been there
so i think maybe like our last year she
was in like her first or second oh my
god it's one of them ones anyway i'mma
read out to you
so this is how my ex-boyfriend spoke to
me on valentine's day after i got his
name tatted on my private parts i can't
believe you're not with me on
valentine's day question question
after a year on this
did you or do you love me
did i mean anything to you
why the [ __ ] do you link me every other
day for a year
he's replying dot
dot convenience
heartbreak she replies heartbreak
why you make me cook for you why do you
make me cook breakfast for you every
sunday
why'd you ask me to get your name tied
on my v why
he's replying dot dot dot allow it
explain
dot dot dot
bro you make good breakfast
so you never loved me you came here
every other day for a year because you
wanted pom-pom and breakfast question
question question he's typing type and
typing and it just locks off there
can you imagine ah some brothers are
brutal bro can you imagine
brother brutal
i don't if you're trying to
to be fair
if you're trying to lock someone off
yeah that's the penis way to do it no
pain is brutal but that's a surefire way
yeah
because
yeah that's tough but it's it's one of
them wasn't because i've seen s not
similar but i've seen somewhat back and
forth between not necessarily back and
forth but her posting about him
in the past like shade room or whatever
it gets picked up on that
and this is not the first occurrence of
him trying to just dead this whole thing
they've not to my knowledge they've not
dated in years you know and she's still
playing this
i don't even understand this could to be
fair this could be an old i sincerely
hope it is this could be a very old back
and forth but the way it looks i said
convenient convenience that's all he
wrote why did you come here all the time
eating my breakfast you make good
breakfast you make good breakfast what
do you want me to say
fam sometimes women want honesty but
honesty is not honesty enough you know
yeah fam so you came here every other
day for pom-pom and breakfast i would
replied you've literally just answered
your question
does that not sound sublime to you
does not know it sounds sublime [ __ ]
and breakfast we'll see him breakfast he
doesn't want to come right i'll come
around every day if i could
it's a [ __ ] and breakfast bro
what are we talking about here it's a
win-win it's a dub dub stop asking me
rhetorical questions let me get on my
day
let me see what the scrambled eggs are
saying like about spam
scrambled eggs are fluffy and your
croissants are warm
and the tomtom is wet
well it's a tick tick tick what else did
you expect brother yeah you know what
else did you expect oh it's um
it's a cruel world it is a cruel guys
can be savage when they need to yeah the
thing is that's me
when i'm done yeah
i can be as cutthroat as i need to be to
make you stop texting me
because i'm not the kind of guy that
likes blocking people oh i i don't block
yeah i've
very i think i've brought like less than
five people in my life like i don't
block it unless i absolutely have to
i would rather just let you know in the
most stern way possible
like done this this yeah us over brother
oh you have no idea how over it is yeah
yeah yeah so this whole you didn't love
me you just used me for pullman
breakfast yeah yes yeah
yes
what did you expect you can you can ask
me this love thing as much as you want
yeah yeah yeah i'm telling you to your
face it was just convenient your
convenience and breakfast
tough times man i couldn't be on the
receiving end of that oh i couldn't i
couldn't be on the receiving side i
think i could you think yeah i think i
could easily
if i was messaging a girl saying big man
like
not like i could ever see me in this
situation but if i could message a girl
saying right like you don't love me like
what why was you over here every then
every day then
because you're a great cook and you
supply sublime dick
that's why i was there every day because
i ate for free and i ate well
and i was piped to sleep every night
that's why i was there how would that
make you feel do you feel double-edged
i'd feel
because you're complimenting me also
exactly
that's why i'm saying double-edged yeah
yeah you're
you're giving me a stern compliment
stern compliment
because i can't argue with logic yeah
like
as much as i am like a living breathing
human with emotions yeah i
very rarely get riled up by logic okay
like i'm someone i'm an advocate for
when people say it shouldn't be this way
or it's not fair i'm always the kind of
person that's like it doesn't matter if
it's fair or not it doesn't matter if
you think it should or shouldn't be this
way the fact is this is nature and this
is life and it is this way
regardless of what you think should or
shouldn't be done
this is life get on with it
you're wasting too much time on these
semantics yeah this is life
i'm giving you logics and facts so i try
my best when i've ever been an argument
manual or whatever i try and use purely
logic and
i failed myself if i say yeah but that's
not fair if you ever hear me in an
argument say yeah but that's not fair
i've already lost the argument okay
because no one said what's fair it's
fact or not fact so if i was arguing
with a girl and said ras so you're
telling me you don't love me you're
using me for dick and breakfast and she
said big man
you cook good breakfast and you give
good dick why would i not be there every
other day
what's his love chat about yeah yeah
logic logic when you hit me that kind of
logic i don't think i can be upset yeah
i'd feel swindled yeah
i was sweet i would look at the message
and read it for five minutes i wouldn't
know what to respond because it like i
said it's double-edged you were like
[ __ ] out that's fact that's a
compliment but [ __ ] i fell used
[ __ ] i felt used yeah 100
but then again like a lot i feel like a
lot of relationships are very
transactional
in in some aspects yes of course yeah
because at the end of the day
that chick for example she clearly felt
loved up into this point where he's
telling her facts convenience and porn
and breakfast yeah
up into that point she clearly felt
loved enough to tattoo man's name on her
palm
that's i've completely forgot she even
said that that's nuts so clearly this
relationship was purely transactional
yeah she got everything from him that
she felt
emotionally she got she felt loved and
she felt like willing to love
and he got permanent breakfast
that was the transaction she just didn't
know that's what the transaction was at
the time and i feel like a lot of the
time unless you men are very unless
people are very open and say i'm looking
to marry you have kids with you and have
a relationship with the rest of my life
i feel like unless that's the case a lot
of relationships people might not like
to hear this or they may not admit to
this a lot of relationships vast
majority relationships unless you're
openly being openly committed
um they're transactional
you're seeing you're seeing a girl that
if there's a girl that you know you're
not going to marry
and she knows you're probably never
going to get married this relationship
is transactional you're going there for
something and she's going there for
something yeah and a lot of the time it
may not be the same thing so if you're
lucky it's the same thing and then we've
got that's when these friends with
benefits come up yeah yeah yeah yeah but
when is that when we're not friends with
benefits but we're never going to get
married this relationship is
transactional
okay i want something you want something
and we're both getting that stuff i hate
you i hear you on that and it's only at
times like this where it's peak where
like
i'm saying to you now big man this was a
transaction
i wanted to pull my breakfast
i was given said puma breakfast
and i know you wanted to feel sweeted
yeah
and i made you feel that way i gave you
a clout and sweet
you wanted to date a rapper and you want
to feel good about yourself yeah and
that's what you got i want a pum and i
want breakfast and that's what i got
i'm sorry you had to hear it this way
tough very tough and i feel like one of
them was
obviously it only got to that point
because
she didn't hear the word no i'm a human
you shouldn't hear the word yeah in a
sense that
she
i want to assume
she was like mothering him in a way for
him to
be so harsh in that in that instance you
know does that make sense oh you think
he was pushed to this point as i put
because no one just speaks out of the
speaks like that essentially i don't
think i'm also not a rapper
i'm with you true but i'm also not
around
who he wants
so this is true
he might jump to 10 immediately true
true convenience
nah man that's tough i haven't got the
balls to say something like that
i really don't i would get misspelled
who the [ __ ] do you think you are that's
what that's the response i'd get back
who the [ __ ] do you think you are um
sharp left turn yeah hit me
controversial topic but it's facts now
okay
speaking of swindord yeah
the tinder swindler yeah has proved to
me personally i'm not gonna say spread
to everyone has proved to me
that council culture doesn't exist if
you are transparent with who you are
because he's still up about and popping
because
the tinder spindler currently
has like an agent in
so he's doing 20 grand club appearances
he's killing it on like cameo and [ __ ]
people are feeding into
who this guy is as the villain
people he he is a villain and people
know him through and through a civilian
so as long as he's still willing to be a
villain
he's doing much worse [ __ ] than other
people that aren't playing the villain
are getting cancelled for yeah do you
know what i mean yeah if he was
a quote unquote good guy
if he was um
a tv personality or an internet
personality of someone who is perceived
to be this
like holier than now good guy to the
world
in the public eye
and then turned around and it turns out
that for the last however many years
he's just been scamming women out of
money
he's going to jail and he's getting
cancelled yeah but because
all we know all the public i know of him
as someone who swindles women out of
their money
he's literally making a living now in
the public eye as that villain and
people are willing to give him money to
be that person but i've also heard that
he's getting sued by the real
um diamond family for using his name or
using their name
that's got nothing to do with being
cancelled
true true true true that's just
negatives from that's the yeah that's
that specific family who said i'm part
of this family and he's not that's not
being canceled true true true that's
literally committing a crime yeah he's
been super because he committed a crime
yeah yeah yeah okay um okay
but in terms of like cancelled in terms
of like yeah like no one will hire you
yeah everything's done basically yeah
yeah like the homeless king away from
her miss prince i don't know where he
was homeless son it was a homeless kid i
think it was homeless homeless king it
was i remember you said it the homeless
king is cleaning up legitimately now
yeah that's mad he made all of his money
from
illegally taking money off it wasn't
illegal actually that's why he's not in
pen right now but
tricking women into giving him money now
he's making this probably the same
amount of money legitimately because he
is a transparent villain these times
these women are probably still paying
back the money they are
100
mud
so it's made me realize that like you
know what
when you are a transparent person
cancer culture attacks people who are
deceiving
like council culture if you paint
yourself as like prime example was um
i feel like enough people saw this that
i won't get in trouble for saying it i
can't get in trouble because i saw what
i saw
i can't get trouble because i saw what i
saw okay i'm intrigued to know what
you're gonna say
i'm intrigued to know what you're gonna
say i saw a tick tock a couple months
ago yeah of rylan
rylan you know the presenter island
maybe by ryland bro the tall guy jet
black hair yes yes yes yes yeah the
brother that does um supermarket sweep
does that only does they put that back
just for him mad
they're better on cinch dot co dot uk
the [ __ ] is that the car thing
i don't know if i'm i hope it's the
right bread our car i've just pulled it
off i just reeled off two ticks brother
i think it's mustache yeah goatee or
whatever it is this spreader yeah yeah
yeah cinch and supermarket sweet brother
yeah yeah yeah
he's active he does like um big
brother's big mouth and then yeah yeah
yeah yeah
yeah so what about him yeah i saw a tick
tock of him
some guy was recording him secretly okay
and then he was saying to this brother i
don't want to put words in his mouth
this is what he said in the tick tocker
big man so he was saying this to the guy
that was recording him yeah the guy was
calling him a secret they're walking
down the street okay guy must have the
phone here okay so you can see like half
of the guy's face and ryland here okay
and he's like like whispering to him
like bro just give me the [ __ ] gear
give me the gear give me the gear ryan's
saying this to the brother yes okay okay
and then ryan clocks the phone
and he's like
oh my god and then he's like [ __ ]
delete that
[ __ ] delete that right now
so
i don't think it's a hop skip at a jump
to say that he was asking for drugs
i don't know what he was asking for
but i don't think he's a hop skip in a
jump to say that gear means drugs
but that's not the the life he puts out
in the public of course not so that kind
of [ __ ] will get you cancelled of course
same with um
was it was her name kaz on um she was on
love island and one of her brethren's
recorded her snorting something in dubai
do you remember that i heard about that
remember this and then i think a few
months later
obviously it went viral viral for like a
few weeks or whatever and then i think a
few weeks later she was promoting saturn
kaz was i think it was kaz i could be
completely wrong but the name kaz is
sticking to my head
so let's go with her she's she was now
promote inside and it was an obvious
ploy to distract everyone from what had
just happened three four weeks ago and
nothing's happened since you know hmm
not she was live brother like
live
and it's like this was your brethren let
alone a stranger recording it your
brethren did this
mad it's nuts to me sometimes people
want you
people don't want to cancel you they
want to make sure they can hold you
hostage when they can yeah 100
they don't really want to cancel you
know they just want to hold you hostage
and run you dry when they can when they
need 100
i couldn't believe it but yeah it
definitely made me realize like because
i think there was another thing off
danny dyer got caught smart and coke or
something like that i'm not too sure if
i saw that one but same with the council
culture team yeah i think he was like a
big like a big man thing i'm danny dyer
i've been snorting yeah yeah if you
didn't know that's your business
leave me to my line yeah my lines leave
me to my lines yeah um but i genuinely
believe that like
council culture preys on people who are
um
to be fair brings back to batman a big
premise of the batman thing is that the
riddler was killing off people who are
liars
okay
just liars these men are liars and they
deserve to die
um and i feel like in a weird horrible
way that's what council culture is is
like if you just project if you just
project the personality that you are
the transparency of your transparency of
it all
and
uh then then that's
there's nothing what what can be
cancelled yeah
i've been this i've been this person
yeah yeah but when you project yourself
as this like holier than now
like if we saw
like
fern cotton getting backshoted in an
alley
no one's gonna know what's going on yeah
that's that's gonna rattle everyone yeah
the nation's gonna run mad yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah but that's certainly
outside that if you did get caught back
trying to like you would like fair play
right
[Laughter]
um so yeah i genuinely believe that like
fair player like
tinder was made me open my eyes i think
he if anyone else did what he did yeah
he was already in the public eye
pretending to be not that they're done
in it they are done but because he is
just portrayed as this villain he just
leans into being the villain and he can
just do it once it's insane the fact
that he's got an agent is insane
and the thing is if he got caught even
now that he's in the public eye if he
then swindled someone else would be like
this [ __ ] guy
he's done it again again
no one's going to be mad no one could be
mad they'd be more mad at the woman of
course of course
her down
it would hunter they'll make her the
victim
it's nuts
yeah um
so yeah man
i
counter cultures are
touch
ruse
it never happens to us man it's just
crazy you just gotta stay as transparent
as you can stay
all there is to it fair fair
yeah you might as well start lying about
yeah
you might as well start lying about [ __ ]
just in case you're really off the chest
now yeah
that's hilarious um but yeah man i found
that truly fascinating
really fascinating um anyway i've been
excited because we missed it last week
twitter hall of fame hall
it's been a minute since we've done that
one of my favorite segments
someone said to start saying
i don't have change sorry when guys move
to you outside
oh imagine
can you even imagine brother
he mad you walk up to a gal
and she's like sorry sorry i haven't got
changed sorry
you'd want to scream at the top of your
lungs oh one moment of screaming at ear
to death as well you prick
sorry i don't have change
you couldn't be with your boys i swear
to god i couldn't hear a girl say that
to you
i swear to god bro
i could not hear a girl say that to you
oh my god sorry i don't have change
oh i would scream i would scratch the
pavement
i would jump to my knees and i'll
scratch the pavement laughing
bro you're done in this town 100
oh i imagine that's [ __ ] funny
sorry i don't have change you would go
home and crawl under your bed and live
there for a week
you would have to
you would have to
because you are done in this space yeah
wow it's tough it's that's tough oh
whoever thought of that wow you man are
you amanda go for the jugular
grown men live tweet in euphoria when
there's nba basketball one
live tweeted oh now euphoria's bar boy
it's dope it's dope i don't know what
man i hate it i want live to eat but
you're furious though all right my
brother's wife left him and remarried
and the way i feel joy for her for her
when she's throwing a new husband heart
eyes heart eyes because family or not
trash is trash oh wow
oh wow that's tough
it's tough
fair enough i stuttered during lecture
today and one of my kids said not you
glitching i had to remember my position
because i almost told her something
that's tough oh bro there was one that
reminds me of one that i uh sent to you
an ah a little while ago man
i sent it to you
also i'm starting no no no no no no no
no no no
no no no
let me find it i don't know if i've
still got it let me see give me a sec or
what's up on whatsapp i'm sure it was oh
there's almost someone i still have it
uh yeah you might have it because i
deleted
all my whatsapp a few months ago maybe
less than
because
my [ __ ] was full
oh is it the grade eight one my grade
eight yeah read it out please i can't
remember what but yeah yeah really i
really don't read it right now
because you even said it to me
my grade eight my grade dates asked me
how many boyfriends i've had in my life
so i started counted
when i reached four one kid shouted
she's made for the streets
imagine i couldn't do it eight
she's made for the streets
oh that's humiliating i wouldn't even as
a teacher i wouldn't know what to do or
say because there's nothing you can do
once these man are like at 12. you can't
retaliate you cannot retaliate made for
the streets
jesus just had four boyfriends um i'd
close my book and walk out the club oh i
promise you'll be the worst teacher the
class is done i'll be the worst teacher
because i will retaliate
and you would yeah you'd lose it all
your mom's made for the streets
your mum's made for the streets you'd
lose it all brother 100
oh
i told my six-year-old we're having
sandwiches for dinner he told me he did
too much homework to be eating
sandwiches for dinner you prick
[Laughter]
bro
random i don't know why
did you when you was a kid did you ever
used to come home
and [ __ ] hate what was for dinner if
you'd had a busy day and you would
worked about
like a hero's appetite he rose up it's
like um
i want to say yes but nothing really
sticks to mind right i'll tell you what
my mom used to [ __ ] with when you were
kids yeah bro
i don't know if this is like an irish
thing
but or like maybe just like a white
person thing
there were times so obviously picture
this you're a teenager it's the middle
of summer
and obviously because it's summer you're
out of course i would go straight i've
been in school all day i've probably had
a ham sandwich and some chris to sustain
me yeah yeah i get home i have a have a
couple maryland cookies yeah yeah
a quick shower in the chamber
change couple maryland cookies and i'm
out i'm playing football until from like
four until like eight or nine
i'm going home [ __ ]
starving yeah and because it's summer
mum wants to give me a light summer meal
she used to give me salad
with boiled eggs and tuna in it
for dinner
for dinner i'd launched a table i'd
launched the [ __ ] table who had i
used to run upstairs and scream into my
pillow
that took my breath away
i went to spark ball or something a
lasagna a shepherd's pie sound dense i
was just about to say something with
density i'm just about to say dance yeah
raw
salad lettuce leaves
boiled eggs which i hate and tuna with
some mayo on the side
and summer's dinner oh
and i used to say black mob man why this
should be like oh it's too hot for satin
heavy
what does that even mean
mandem in african that man them on the
equator eat heavy every day rice what
are you talking about chicken rice
for breakfast in nigeria
what are you talking about all them
thing there
i'm starving should make some homemade
potato salad with some boiled potatoes
and the whole thing was cold
oh no the eggs weren't even warm brother
the whole thing was cold after them kind
of exercises you need food food i've
been sweating all day hot food
to settle the stomach i need carbs i was
ah it oh it's triggering me just
thinking about it i can tell i i swear
to god i used to run upstairs and scream
into my pillow
and just spend the whole night shaking
in hunger
oh with some salad cream and emptying
there
[ __ ] it i want to launch it
i would launch it sorry moving on i
would launch the whole [ __ ] table
[ __ ] that
during the london riots guys were really
out here changing their bbm names to
luta vandross
[Laughter]
bro
bro this one hands up this is me
the main character syndrome
the main character syndrome is strong in
me because i can't believe the african
cup of nations went on without nigeria
expected them to cancel it
as soon as that jira got kicked out
you thought the thing was done they
should have just canceled the whole it's
pointless now
that was me main character syndrome was
me bro
yeah that's jokes
that's actually funny i expected them to
cancel it
the final was boring for me was um
egypt and where's sadio manny played for
again where's he from
it's not cameroon no it was um
it begins with s note it was
senegal senegal yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] it to be fair
that was me
with england and the euros
i was thinking it doesn't make sense for
us to lose at this point yeah it's our
turn yeah exactly exactly impossible
exactly bro it's our turn exactly so
when we lost against it i was thinking
i'll see it then
that's it then
that's just it then okay cool
save cancel everything cancel everything
family wasted time money everything yeah
yeah the whole tournament was a waste of
time exactly it was based around us yeah
literally not even just for england fair
everyone's supporting us clearly
everyone wanted us to win that's what
was going on in my head it doesn't make
sense for us to lose this
bro it was wow mad
all right my cousin caught her do
cheating she put her iphone in his car
and did find iphone and her son's on her
son's ipad sorry and found the girl's
address
my granny said you do know this
detective work imagine you went to
college and applied yourself
bro i've been saying this for years
the energy some people
the energy some women's particularly put
into catching their man cheating
if they put that into a business yeah if
they put that into some entrepreneurial
spirit
they'd be
millionaires
entrepreneurial spirit
they'll be [ __ ] millionaires oh my
days that's hilarious
i told this girl we're done and she
replied we never started oh my bro i'm
about to cry
yo
wow
i'll have to reply to shane
you heartless
again this in fam this one hands up this
is me
growing up in a nigerian home
dad is back is not an announcement it's
a warning
hundred percent brother when i heard the
car door slam looking out the window
make sure it's him fam i have to make
sure everything's organized that was me
when my hatter came out to make sure the
washing's done i had to make sure the
food was ready and i had to make sure my
room was clean bro fam oh i hated it oh
i hated it was washing dishes
hoovering and mopping the floor
and
bringing in the water if the washroom
was in on the land yeah that needs to be
brought in and folded
bought and folded on everyone's base
if my mom rocked home at five and that
wasn't done b arm's house arms house
beef she will bail me yeah without my
voice she will bail me
cuss me and then before i say anything
she'll hang up
i used to walk home just dreading
you take the long way home the long way
home for some reason i'm not riding my
bike i'm walking my bike for some reason
a long way as quick as well oh my god
the long way home is quick that day
it's the scariest thing and then you
walk through the door you put your keys
in your door and you're like hi
you're in nothing you know you you you
can hear the tv so you know they're in
there hi
no response and you're like [ __ ]
[ __ ] up i [ __ ] up i'm dead
parents were brutal
oh the vibrator died while brian and i
were [ __ ] and this [ __ ] said
and now it's time for the acoustic set
that's
funny
the tracking number isn't enough i need
to be on the delivery driver's private
story
bro
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
fam when these men say it's going to be
between 11 and 3
where are you where are you bro
where are you
he's private
that's hilarious
everyone raise the hand up for that
[ __ ] owe you a little money and
start appearing offline on playstation
i'm sweating
[Laughter]
appearing offline on
playstation oh jesus dudes be 6'5 250
pounds just to end up working at
t-mobile
and that's so true brother i've seen
some huge [ __ ] just doing some
dainty-ass jobs it's like you're wasting
everything god gave you i've seen that
so many times i've seen that
oh that's peak my ex said you're never
going to find someone like me
[ __ ] that's the plan
that's what you said [ __ ] that's
the plan
i read this and i'm thinking this is
fair this is facts
being a baby must be traumatizing at
times imagine going to sleep in your
yard and you wake up in woolworths
[Laughter]
bro
fact that literally is facts
oh
random when you were this is stupid
maybe even not even younger did you ever
used to
did you used to get like um envious of
babies you know when you're walking down
the street and the rat is raining and
they're in the buggy and they have that
rain cover yep yeah yes there's the news
they don't have to walk
the [ __ ]
this rain cover thing and all they're
hearing is that like
serenading them before they sleep yeah
mum yeah man literally your mom wake up
sad girls give the best head because
they don't care about breathing anymore
a lie that's tough wow indeed wow indeed
wow
i'll do one more i think where is it
gone
my dad went jogging this morning some
minutes later he called me to bring the
car to come and pick him up
why are you looking at me like that g
fun
that's
[ __ ]
hilarious
oh he's calling me to come and pick him
up you know i remember fam i remember i
don't remember what summer it was but i
was still living in london
my dad
i was still working at grill in the
market for sure
i think it was the day i went to work my
dad went jogging he was trying to keep
um stay healthy and stuff this was going
on at least
six seven years ago at least
and i think i was off the next day and
so was he we were chilling chilling chin
man said he could have walked today
he said he's his body he's in bits and
bobs he said he could have walked and he
said i was like what did you do he said
i went jogging yesterday oh my god
i was like pops
come on come on nah just a young stretch
of something he's not he's not been
active in a minute oh
i feel
for parents in this room
that could never be me oh he was done i
remember he was hobbling all over the
yard oh
[ __ ] say less is corn socks
that's dread yeah he's probably never
jogged since he doesn't why would you he
doesn't want literally why would he
doesn't want that anymore um
that was [ __ ] funny bro
this is a long episode
let's wrap it there please yes um my
head's pounding from that laughter
pounding um guys i'm ill
you know the drill
um
please chap sitting in the comments like
the video if you like the video if
you're listening to listening to this on
audio
please uh leave a review it means a lot
to us and i actually quite enjoy reading
them same i've read quite a few of them
i've had pretty much mostly i've pretty
much read all of them and as always guys
we're happy to be here happy to have you
here if you can't wait till next monday
hop on on patreon.com forward slash
shits in gigs and catch our latest
episode coming out this thursday you man
love love love gang going okay blessed
[Music]